Alright, so now we're going to buy our domain for our website.
We usually use GoDaddy, I know there's tons of other options you can have, so pick whatever
you like.
I'm just showing you again what we use.
So once you create an account, you are going to search for your domain.
And what we like to pick is ideally first the city and then the service.
So in our case it would be Queen Creek Concrete.
And we always like it to end with .com.
Search domain, let's see if that's available.
So we don't want to spend that much.
And GoDaddy will show you the options that you have.
So let's try to flip it.
Let's do Concrete and then QueenCreek.com, see if that's available, see if it's not available.
So what we like to do is put the location back and just put a little divider right there,
put Concrete, alright, search domains, ok that's available.
So perfect.
We definitely never want to switch to .com, we don't want to do .co, .net, blah blah
blah.
So QueenCreek.com, continue to cart, perfect.
We definitely just want to do a year to start off.
And then we always like to add the full domain protection, so get it.
And then I'm ready to pay.
And then complete purchase.
And after we're done purchasing we're going to connect it to our Weebly website, should
be fairly simple.
There you go, perfect.
So I am going to continue connecting to an existing site.
Ok, and the destination is Weebly, right here.
Connect domain.
Ok, and here is going to give you the steps.
Go to Weebly, click edit next to your site, want to connect, click settings and then click
change under site.
So make sure you copy this right here, command copy, go back to Weebly, and what we like
to do is click publish just to save it.
So we're going to click save and publish, we like to just do the pro up here.
The reason why we publish it, it's because that's how you save websites on Weebly.
So anytime you make an edit, make sure you always click the publish, publish, publish.
Then we're going to click exit, now you can click out of it.
So this is our website that we built.
Click, just click right here, don't click on edit website, just click right here, ok.
Click on these three dots and then edit domain.
You're going to click provide your domain and you're going to paste in the domain that
you just bought.
Click save, perfect, and then you're actually going on edit website, ok, domain, click on
settings, we want to change that.
So just name it the same as the page title, queen creek concrete, uncheck that, click
save, enable SSL, ok, it should tell you that, then click publish again, because again we
always want to save everything that we're doing, ok, perfect, and you're done.
And just so you know, right now it says not secure, because when we clicked on settings,
it's still doing it.
So just make sure you check on it later and it is secure and you're done, that's all you
need to do.